[Inaudible].
Hey, what's up everybody. Chrissy histories here. I'm today.
I want to talk about the American revolutionary war and how it didn't start out
as a war for freedom against the English.
And it was kind of a revolutionary war,
a civil war and a world war all-in-one queue.
So it all starts with the French and Indian war,
which was like 20 years before that.
And that had the French and Indians or native Americans, indigenous people,
French and Indians verse, the British and her loyal subjects, the Americans.
So how wild is that? Initially?
We're on the British side and the French and Indian war fighting against the
French who during the revolutionary war are going to come to our side.
Doesn't matter, war stupid, but French and Indian war.
We went them Americans and the British. We win that war.
George Washington himself was a Colonel in the,
in the British army during the French and Indian war and help them win the war.
So it's just all wild. The foreshadowing was like, Oh, bananas.
But we fight that war for them. As the 13 colonies, we fight them.
And, uh,
we helped the British win and retain her colonies and all this stuff that was
going on in the French and Indian war that's for another day,
but we help them win, but Wars cost money, right? So England is like, yo,
we have no money because I need to win a war. Especially is like,
who's going to spend the most money. That's usually what war is,
who spends the most money. So we win and Britain says,
okay, now we don't have any money. So what do they do?
They're like let's tax the people that helped us win the war.
Let's tax our loyal subjects to 13 colonies. And we're like, why though?
We just, we die for you. And when blood for you,
and now we have to pay more money for stamps. So the stamp act of 17,
seven of 17, 65 was like an F to us. I'm like,
we just helped you win the war WTF. But anyway, it starts to cause issues.
So the first kind of ideas of a war against England,
start with that. It starts with taxation without representation. We're saying,
Hey, you're going to tax us on stamps and teas and all these other goods,
but not let us be represented in parliament in London. Like what gives.
So it starts to get, we start to get off. And then we start to say,
we're not going to pay for the stamps. We're burning things down.
We start to F with the British soldiers on, you know, in New York and Boston,
the Boston massacre, the Boston tea party.
And it starts to people off King George. The third was like, why are these guys,
man? It's like, are you stupid? And kind of was so we're like, listen, um,
we're going to fight. We're going to start fighting you.
We're going to start fighting with 1775, but it's not about freedom.
We don't want to be free from you.
We're fighting you because we want to have legal representation in parliament.
If you're going to tax us for teas and stamps and all that other.
So we start to fight. We'll start getting our asses handed to us span. I mean,
we're losing Britain at that time was the biggest fiercest fighting force fierce
in the whole world. So we're getting our asses handed to us. I mean,
we're the 13 colonies. We're not the mighty United States.
There were just 13 colonies. So we don't even have shoes. I mean,
we're farmers with pitchforks trying to pick up muskets.
We barely know how to use,
to fight the most formidable fighting force in the world at the time.
So we're getting our handed to us. And then towards, you know,
the spring of 1776,
the soldiers are like putting their guns down on the American side.
And George Washington is like, Hey, we need to fight. And we're like, no,
they're like, yo, you got fight, bro. Like my farm is being rammed sack,
who knows what happened to my wife and kids. Everybody's dying.
I got no shoes on my feet are bleeding and we're losing this fricking war.
So the founding fathers at the time come up with an idea.
That's where the American ingenuity. I mean, it's just, it's great.
They come up with an idea and they say George Washington and Ben Franklin and
Thomas Jefferson and Alex Hamilton wax center,
Hamilton wasn't even a big deal yet. He was still,
he was just a regular soldier, but you know,
he still probably had something to do with it because I mean the play Hamilton,
but they start to say, okay,
how can we get the soldiers to stay and not put down their guns? I got it.
Independence.
Let's come up with the idea of independence from England.
Not just taxation without representation. That's minor.
Let's go major declaration of independence. So they get Thomas Paine.
It's great. This pamphlet called common sense here.
Thomas Paine was a great orator. He could, Thomas Paine was like, uh,
he could just sling lyrics. He was like the Kanye West of the time.
He could just get people to move.
He was slang in these lyrics doing a great job.
So Thomas Paine comes up with common sense and the pamphlet goes through the 13
colonies saying, we need freedom from this mighty tyranny government of Britain.
And so it starts to ignite the colonists, right? The colonists say, yes,
we're going to, we're going to get back in. We're going to the army.
Start to triple and quadruple after common sense.
Cause like freedom from England. So as the years go on, I mean we,
yeah, we're doing okay, but you know, cause we got more soldiers,
but we're still getting our asses handed to us until the battle of Saratoga in
the battle of Saratoga, which is widely known as the turning point of the war,
we get a real nice decisive victory against the British and that makes France
Britain's mortal enemy on the sideline.
Even know we fought against them 20 years ago in the French and Indian war.
It makes France say, you know what? I kind of like these little colonists.
So we're going to join.
And France sends pretty much their entire army and Spain also Britain's mortal
enemy sends money. So Spain sending money on the wall. They're like,
you know what? We're not going to spend on soldiers,
but we're going to send you guys some casts. So they started wearing from Flint.
So they send, they send money. France sends their army,
which Frances unbelievable fighting force to.
You got to understand at that time in the 17 hundreds,
we didn't even have a Navy. The Americans did not have a Navy.
Britain has the most powerful Navy in the whole world.
So France sends their Navy, which is like, thank you.
So we start to fight them. And then the war, the tide of the war starts to turn.
So it's also a civil war though, as I mentioned,
because a lot of people were called loyalists back then and they were
loyal to the British crown.
They did not want to necessarily fight against England because they were like,
yo, they, England was really that bad to us.
So you had a lot of people in their own families. You would have one brother,
a revolutionary war, soldier fighting with the 13 colonies and the,
and the continental army and the other brother loyalists putting on a red,
a dirty red coat and fighting with the British enemy.
So it's like a civil war and you're like, bro, what the?
So we start winning as the F once the F once France joins, we start winning,
right? And we all know, by the way, we almost,
there's so many times during this revolution where we really almost lost.
I mean, thank God for the weather, Jesus Christ himself. I know for fact,
he's an American kid and he bleeds red, white,
and blue because the war was almost all about loss at the battle of Brooklyn in
August of 1776, because we had our whole army pin,
George Washington, and we had the army pan and we're like, yo, bro,
we're going to die. We're going to surrender.
But then a mighty fog rolls in the British were going to come and advance on us
the next morning. Right? Cause they had us pinned in this Hamlet, right.
And we had our backs against the wall backs against the water. And um, we,
we thought we were going to lose. And so at this mighty Fargo's end,
George Washington says, you know what? You can know what,
let's get our whole army on these boats that are trapped and sail them across
the water, underneath the guise of this fog. And the British will never know.
And lo and behold, the British go to storm the next morning,
there's two colonial soldiers there. And it's like, yeah, take me Dick head.
The rest of the army got across the water.
They were up into Harlem and they escaped to live another day because the thing
with George Washington is he really wasn't the greatest military tactician,
even though listen, he's my boy Memorial day. I love you, George Washington,
thank you for saving this country, but you weren't really that great on the,
as a military tactician, what he was very, very,
very good at is he knew what all the people said about him,
Benjamin Franklin and Thomas Jefferson, all those guys.
What they said about George Washington is he, he,
he had the ability. He had the ability to say, you know what? We're not,
I'm not going to win. He knew that he wasn't going to win. He could see this,
his exact quote from Benjamin Franklin.
This is something you can take your own life. He said,
the greatest thing about George Washington is he was able to see things as they
were not as he wishes they were. So that's little life advice.
You know, you can apply that to anything. And especially in military battles,
it's like George Washington knew I'm not going to sit and fight.
The British were going to kill us in Brooklyn. I know that we're going to lose.
So let me get these ships across the water and get to safety. So boom safe.
So as time goes on, we start to really win cause that colonial American spirit,
we start to really win. And then eventually of course, we beat the British.
We make them surrender at Yorktown, um, down in the South on,
in 1781 because you know, it was really France, uh, that really, you know,
kind of helped us with the, they, they taught our military what to do.
That's why, when people like we hate France,
it's like why they gave us a country. Thank you, France. Like shout out,
Baghat's shout out pink Panther, like whatever, like shout out France.
Thank you. Um, so they helped us win the war, um, uh,
by sending all their troops to us. And you know,
of course the Marquis de Lafayette who was a 21 year old soldier and Rashaan
ball, rumble, Shaun, and I would say his name.
He was a great military leader there taught, uh, George Washington, um,
kind of a lot of military tactics and all our people, military tactics. Um,
and it was so, you know, and so,
so it really goes beyond just America versus Britain though,
because it is a world war. I mean, Spain sent money, France joined us,
you know, we fought against England,
the Netherlands joined and there are all these repercussions as time went on,
it was kind of like really the first world war, our first civil war.
And of course the revolution, I mean,
every country got involved pretty much in the revolutionary
war except China, because God knows what China is doing.
They're probably making viruses and putting them in bats when they could have
been helping us. But yeah, I don't know if I was supposed to say that,
but listen, I'm nine minutes in, so I can't go back now.
So I'm just going to post it.